E aí
[Música]
Oi boa tarde a todos que eu sou Madalena
e provavelmente vocês estão a pensar no
que é que eu vim aqui fazer hoje eu
queria dizer com vela para dar esta
toque porque ter um curso Ensina em 3
meses quebrar muitos recordes vou
brincar mais ou menos
e eu acho que encontramos a minha
história antes de mais gostava de saber
pintar com uma espécie de breve retrato
representa a pessoa que eu era antes de
tudo acontecer bom Eu Era exatamente a
mesma maneira que sou hoje mas agora
tenho muito mais conhecimentos de
medicina em - 1 - a bandeira do verão
2019 era uma rapariga saudável cama 12
não é na sala né 19 anos com muitas
vezes as passagens tudo me e que está a
ver com a menina falar de Lisboa e que
era Mega saudável e foi isso que me
safou-se
o Anjo disse Anna embarca em uma viagem
que deu uma volta de 360 graus a minha
vida deixando para alguns meses de
pernas para lá para entender eu e minha
família estávamos a viajar pela Costa
amalfitana no primeiro dia que a mim se
a greve no dia vinte e seis de Julho
acordei bastante enjoada é sentir um
cansaço fora do normal e cheio de dor de
cabeça no entanto se desvalorizar estes
sintomas no dia seguinte fomos de carro
até à Veneza mas eu tive que virar uma
Papa parar o carro eu estava realmente
muito enjoada vomitei tive uma cadeira
atenção é só um esquema gastroenterite
Por isso a minha mãe foi até a farmácia
e vamos comprar uns quilinhos para
barriga eu levo não conhecia tudo que eu
consegui ingerir foi mais sumo de fruta
três dias que eu tive Veneza como se a
cidade apenas através das fotografias
que o meu pai enviando formato do
WhatsApp porque eu ficava os dias
inteiros no apartamento a tentar aliviar
o mal-estar de alguma forma e a
descansar mas alguns decidi que era hora
de finalmente sair
a idade para poder aproveitar a viagem
no entanto rapidamente emagrecer que não
conseguia andar cinco minutos sem ter
parar para descansar porque realmente
cinco minutos
é esta sensação de mal-estar
infelizmente manteve-se até ao meu
regresso a Portugal eu cheguei a chorar
porque eu não conseguia subir umas
escadas aterrar em Lisboa na noite de 31
anos eu tive outra queda de tensão no
avião é só não quero a falta de açúcar
no sangue portanto se dividiram uns 10
conjuntos de roupa algumas eu já não
consigo era sabe da frente no entanto
continuei passar mal o voluntários
o e finalmente que eu consegui convencer
a minha mãe levar no hospital quando
chegamos fomos diretas ao posto de
Socorro do aeroporto onde um menino
atenção e pressiona que ela está
realmente muito baixinha chamaram uma
ambulância eu fui levada para o hospital
mais próximo de Santa Maria é curioso
porque a última coisa que me lembro é
das fotos da ambulância se fecharem no
entanto eu tive o nos dois dias que se
seguiram quando cheguei ao hospital
fizeram algumas análises e o primeiro
diagnóstico foi de uma gastroenterite
aguda no entanto não tinha certeza do
que está a passar comigo portanto
quiserem que eu ficasse a passar a noite
no s o em observação
é um dos médicos que fizeram um
conversor inclusive que quando me
conheceu achou que eu não passava de uma
Adolescência a idade do armário fazer
fita porque eu realmente tinha um
momento em que eu parecia o time e dez
minutos depois já salão morrer
literalmente eu estava mesmo morrer no
dia seguinte eu fui levada para o nele
que elas intermédios onde continuar a
ter as minhas famosas quebra extensão e
perder sentidos após uma igual grafia
operação concluíram que não passava de
uma gastroenterite mas ainda estavam
estudar o meu caso
e no dia seguinte a nessa noite não é
que segunda gosto eu passei mesmo muito
mal a minha mãe contou-me que eu tive
comigo mas não exista durante 12 horas
se atentar aliviar meus Sofrimentos e as
minhas dores embora sem sucesso me disse
assim se um dia dois de agosto eu fui
levado a qualidade que elas intensivos
por que a situação era realmente muito
grave acontece que eu tinha não há um
vírus nem a sabe quando nem onde que se
instalou no coração provocando assim uma
melhor Perry Acredite linfocítica
fulminante basicamente uma informação de
músculo cardíaco do miocárdio e da sua
membrana do pericárdio Eu sinto que não
tenho que explicar esta audiência porque
o maior parte de vocês entendem do
assunto mas é clássico automático o meu
coração começou que deve ser bater uma
inicialmente intensidade serão
aproximadamente 20 dias de Roma e eu
passei para os primeiros lugares na
lista de espera para transplante de
coração dada a urgência com o meu
coração não bateu suficiente todos os
meus órgãos não tiveram o sangue
necessitavam
o original de uma situação de choque
cardiogênico acompanhar primeira
exposição múltipla de órgãos nesse
momento eu não tinha coração não tinha
rins e Meu fígado não funcionava para
compensar a usam renal aguda filial da
hemodiálise foi-me colocada uma sonda no
estômago para me alimentar entre o coma
eu tive hemorragia digestiva tão
complicada é que originou uma sensação
de choque hemorrágico fazendo com
comercial de uma transfusão de sangue
foi só a primeira de muitas o fígado
manter sem funcionar e o mal foi
substituído por um ventiladores o
coração por sua vez foi substituído por
uma máquina chamada é como um tratamento
de oxigenação com uma membrana a
extracorporal que retira tudo sangue que
existe não se gênio no corpo humano
enriquecido com oxigênio e a rir entre
dois novamente através de uma artéria
até da minha perna direita aqui agora é
a minha perna brilhante conta das
máquinas ligadas a mim não conseguiam
colocar uma ambulância para ser
transferida para Santa Marta onde são
feitos os transplantes de coração
Portanto o que era através da e
comercializarem para me colocar um
coração
o produto para ser transferida para lá
posto este ninguém garanti os meus pais
com e sobreviver dizemos que não se
agarrar sem nada e que a situação era
mesmo muito grave
hoje eu acordei no dia de hoje no dia
vinte de agosto sem a mínima noção do
que me tinha acontecido os médicos os
enfermeiros estou a gente à minha volta
são dizer que era muito forte e que eu
era Milagres quando não perceber nada
essa conversa eu até achava começavam
confundir com outra doença então é Só
sorria e acenava eu entrei no hospital
com 73kg e acordei com 38 tinha perdido
toda a massa muscular estava analítica
começar a comer foi tão difícil
surpreendentemente eu achei o processo
de migração do sistema na comida muito
mais difícil do que colocar a minha
prótese e começar a andar eu digo isso
falar comigo né porque eu acho que não a
melhor forma de lidar com este tipo de
situações eu estava completamente nos
real intensivos mas é Leste mesmo a luz
e barulho constante as máquinas não
deixavam ter um ciclo do sono-vigília
regulado portanto eu chegava muitas
vezes ao assinar eu tenho certinho umas
semanas com bastante ocupada nos
cuidados intensivos eu era atriz de
novela As coisas dos meus pais
e com Ele ativa dos enfermeiros
estávamos animais só vemos que queremos
construímos carro suspiros olímpicos
para ir à China ver os olímpicos
vantagens e meus irmãos venham visitar e
assim vamos almoçar com os primos e eu
não achava estranho nunca mais ter
almoçado eu não achava estranho nunca
mais ter nenhuma refeição para a minha
frente e eu ter postado um bocado comigo
e atenção que eu não sabia que não tinha
umas alimentar me até que um dia umas
enfermeiras queria para mim mesmo assim
Madalena está na hora de comer o que é
que te apetece e eu deviam ser para aí
11 da manhã com toda a fé lasanha tem
que ser uma coisa um bocadinho mais
ligeira e sugeriu uma gelatina e acho
que se tinha como eu disse que não podia
ser que ser um iogurte Ela pode ser um
Mimosa de banana e eu odeio banana só
gosto de iogurtes cremosos de bom achou
sabor baunilha manga
e ela disse que isso não tinha uma lá na
sala nessa questão alta ela quis ir
almoçar ver se eles então pela ligar a
minha mãe que a minha mãe trazia a minha
mãe entram pelos cuidados intensivos a
dentro toda contente com a paleta de 20
alguns e eu super feliz porque a dão
aquele iogurtes eu ponho uma colher na
boca e não só não sabe o mesmo como eu
fico imediatamente cheia Não Estou a
brincar eu comi uma colher e fica cheia
a partir daí iniciou-se a derradeira
luta para a força para começar a comer e
ganhar força eu acho que nós não temos
noção da força que temos este meu
sentimento poderem desenvolver-se entre
um discurso inspirador mas o sentido
esta minha frase é literal Imagine só
não tenho força para rolar na cama e
mudar a imposição acharam telemóvel
demasiado pesado eu não consegui
levantar o braço e postar a minha
própria testa e eu tinha que pedir a
minha mãe para fazer e ver o que quer
que fosse é difícil porque eu acordei
sem voz nenhuma as cordas vocais
significado destruídas graças ao
ventiladores
e eu não consigo eu não vi a água
durante 32 dias porque eu não conseguia
viver sem engasgar e morrer de ser a
tempo inteiro essa na verdade é uma
fotografia do primeiro dia que eu
consegui beber água que foi uma grande
vitória
E ainda por cima eu tive a sorte de ter
um lugar privilegiado nas criar os
ensinos mesmo em frente ao sítio onde
eles davam os maus portanto eu vi água a
correr constantemente agora Imaginem o
sofrimento quando a minha maior vontade
era pôr uns até levantar-me e colocar a
minha boca basta acionar a durante três
horas eu não só tive de aprender em
inglês novamente com a falar iniciamos
vou explicar o quão difícil foi por um
de pé pela primeira vez tonturas falta
de força que era só colocar me espera
colocar muito feio que sobrar animação
perna é mesmo 2019 era uma rapariga
totalmente independente e só lavar em
menos de um mês eu voltei ser como um
bebé porque eu gostava de ajuda para
tudo as dores e os seus Fantasmas eram
mais que muitas aliás os testes mas
quando ele poder do como eu não percebi
que não tinha uma perna eu não sou
durante uma semana e meia porque eu
sinto eu lembro como se ela tivesse
o e sentia-me como se o negócio tivesse
é chamar a atenção fantasma
e inclusive e livro um de ter uma
discussão com o Enfermeiro porque eu
pedi para ele colocar a mão falar teus
pés e ele coitado colocava do pé que eu
tenho pé esquerdo e nesse dia com ele
para ele por vasto direito também e ele
coitado não fazia não é impossível E eu
achava que eu não está aparecer o que eu
tava ele pedir porque eu não tinha voz
quando eu descobri meu Deus eu não dei o
hospital Santa Maria com as minhas
lágrimas eu sabia como é que aquele era
possível porque eu lembro me sentindo
muito mal assim mas eu nunca tinha
especificamente uma dor na perna
importante eu não consegui encontrar
Lógico que eu preciso botar lá o
Enfermeiro gostava de mim que no momento
em que eu percebi O Enfermeiro Tiago
isso que eu tinha estado mesmo muito mal
e que passe morrido foi a primeira
pessoa que alguma vez me dissestes eu só
conseguia pensar que só tinha 19 anos e
não tinha a minha perna eu não sabia
como é que os meus amigos e o registo
como é que é o próprio dia que você
quiser dar com esta minha nova imagem
física ou sequer a pessoa para fazer uma
vida normal sem uma perna para ler é
super possível a
e eu acho que foi a partir desse momento
que uma percebi o apoio absolutamente
crucial de profissionais de saúde que
acompanharam Eles foram muito a a
prestação de cuidados de saúde eu estou
convicta que se não fossem eles eu não
teria sido a reação que tive ao que me
aconteceu
é claro que estou eternamente grata por
não terem salva-vida Mas um pouco
psicológico me deram foi a alma do outro
mundo surreal eu não tenho palavras para
agradecer Eu acho que tudo que disseram
nunca vai ser suficiente eles merecem
Tudo são minha segunda família eu não me
canso de dizer
e eu fiquei internada em Santa Maria
dois meses agosto nos cuidados
intensivos e se temos cuidados
intermédios conseguir contra todas as
seguradas recuperar os meus órgãos todos
o coração funciona a 100 porcento o
fígado regenerou e os rins depois quatro
semanas parados começaram a funcionar
novamente a voz voltou depois de muito
estranho e comecei a conseguir comer não
temos bem noção do que é ficar tanto
tempo internado no hospital eu acho que
isso é muito positivo eu depois de do
hospital foi transferida para o centro
de reabilitação alcoitão no dia um de
outubro ontem à noite todos os dias para
me reabilitar é um ambiente bastante
diferente o Hospital de Santa Maria no
entanto foi muito bom para recuperar a
minha Independência a vários níveis e
fui ver a casa ao fim de semana coisas
aquelas já tinha Mesmo muitas muitas
saudades lá também aproveitar para
começar a estudar realizamos o 1º
semestre semana não ficar para trás na
faculdade conseguir fazer eles e passei
a tudo ao todo foram 121 dias em
treinamento
Esse é um centímetro um bocadinho
estranho temos a missão de quase
morremos Eu acho que só a gente sabe que
a vida é algo e febre e com a qualquer
momento se pode escapar mas temos
efetivamente a consciência de que foi
por tão pouco é absolutamente assustador
isso real eu não sabia como é que ia ser
a minha vida mas não vale a pena ficar
triste e pernas já não ia voltar e eu
iria ter que lidar com esta nova
situação mais cedo ou mais tarde tanto
mas ele assim mais cedo eu perdi que
pensamos português porque eu porque em
mim porque agora é do pior que se pode
fazer eu nunca vou ter essa resposta
portanto esse tipo de pensamento só
servem me frustrar então eu coloco os
completamente ao norte a sul do país no
ano 2019 todas as pessoas que uma
infecção no coração com a minha morreram
preciso só consigo estar grata por
continuar cá claro que é Um Desafio e
nem sempre foi fácil ou linear aprender
a viver com uma prótese e aliás meus que
outros estão sempre diesel a minha vida
não é melhor ou pior do que Arantes é
simplesmente diferente porque eu faço
tudo aquilo que eu fazia antes disto
acontecer simplesmente uma forma
Ah tá
e com essa história enorme Eu pretendo
transmitir duas importantes lições que
no fundo se complementam caso não faz
mal ontem posto Figueira Alde mas é
fundamental nunca perdermos o foco
quando eu pensei que não tinha a minha
perna como contar Foi um momento
bastante difícil eu não sabia como é que
ser a minha vida mas o que eu mais
queria era volta para minha vida ao mal
e portanto o caminho comigo ser feito eu
tinha que levantar e ir Militar de
qualquer maneira porque eu queria voltar
para faculdade e eu queria voltar a ser
com as minhas amigas receber passar o
ginásio e pertence porque na hora perder
tempo eu tinha que fazer a minha
realização física de qualquer maneira
mais lidar com a situação agora e não
perder mais tempo
o e sinceramente eu não acho que não
tenho uma perna porque como conseguem
ver a minha vida é quase igual à que era
um ano atrás só como eu disse há bocado
tem muito mais conhecimentos de medicina
e agora tem uma forma brilhante aqueles
que a minimizar que coisa eu só queria
também dizer que ao menos menos bons
Claro não há nenhuma rapariga da minha
data que tenho que mexer em parafusos
joelho para conseguir calçar umas botas
de salto mas cada um tem sua luta e as
suas adversidades e não devemos comparar
aos outros para me dispedir deixo-vos
com uma frase com a qual me identifico é
sem por cento e
e a nossa vida é unicamente tão boa
quanto nós humanos at e por isso é que
nós temos o poder final a melhores
obrigada
[Música]